[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire premières destinations
touristiques de la planète la france a
profité de l'expansion rapide du
tourisme mondial de ces dernières
décennies
un milliard de touristes par an dont 95%
s'agglutinaient sur moins de 5% des
terres immergées
cette expansion était continuer rien
n'aurait dû l'interrompre en comptait
bien atteindre au plus vite les 100
millions de touristes annuels
les 60 milliards d'euros de recettes et
puis la crise du coronavirus a donné un
coup d'arrêt brutal à tout cela si bien
que l'on peut prendre enfin le temps de
se demander s'il y a trop de touristes
ou pas assez et pas seulement en france
partout pour en débattre nous avons
invité saskia cousin elle est
anthropologue spécialiste des politiques
touristiques vous en cdd pratiques
touristiques pas des politiques vous
enseigne à l'université paris diderot
chercheuse au cesm à le centre d'études
en sciences sociales sur les mondes
africains américains asiatiques vous
êtes l'auteur avec bertrand réau de
sociologie du tourisme aux éditions la
découverte
est ce qu'il y avait trop ou pas assez
de touristes d'après vous c'est ce qu'a
cousin un mou il ya trop de touristes
dans certains endroits pas assez dans
d'autres donc la question c'est comment
on compte les touristes comme on les
définit quelles sont leurs pratiques
donc comme comme toute question générale
malheureusement la réponse est complexe
il ya trop de touristes à venise il ya
trop de touristes peut-être à paris il y
en a pas assez dans d'autres endroits
donc en fait repenser la question comme
vous l'avez les 10 et repenser autrement
le tourisme n'est pas forcément soit
l'éradication soit la multiplication des
touristes jean luc michaud vous êtes
économiste et juriste de formation vous
avez été le rapporteur du premier schéma
directeur du tourisme en france c'était
en 1970 vous avez été ensuite l'un des
cofondateurs du conservatoire du
littoral puis le directeur national du
tourisme français en tant qu'élu
régional vous avez présidé au
développement touristique de la région
capitale
aujourd'hui vous présidez l'institut
français du tourisme un think tank que
vous avez créé en 2007 et qui était à
l'origine entre autres du guide
de réussir dans le tourisme paru aux
éditions du guide du routard alors trop
ou pas assez de touristes d'après vous
je compléterai de réponse de saskia
cousin qui me paraît très bonne dans le
sens où il faudrait dire lieu de
tourisme pour résumer mieux de tourisme
d'abord parce que c'est fait on le comte
mal donc il faut être très prudent dans
les conclusions à en tirer
rencontre mal et c'est grave dans un
sens parce que ça déforme la perception
et ça dépend aussi des politiques que
l'on peut conduire parce qu'on apprécie
mal précisément l'étonnant mais surtout
les aboutissants on compte pas dans le
sens où l'organisation mondiale du
tourisme table habituellement vous
l'avez rappelé sur une fréquentation aux
frontières de l'ordre de près d'un
milliard et demi de touristes
aujourd'hui c'est à dire des
déplacements internationaux
en réalité c'est à la fois surestimé
sous-estimé s'est surestimé parce que la
plupart de ses déplacements aux
frontières procède des mêmes voyageurs
qui passent plusieurs frontières
successivement par exemple c'est le cas
de l'europe bien sûr ceux qui viennent
du nord pour aller jusqu'au sud en
espagne ou ailleurs parce 2-3-4
frontières à l'aller et au retour
bref c'est une surestimation singulière
ventes en europe c'est aussi
sous-estimation parce que les
statistiques internationales ne sont pas
des statistiques mondiales
ce sont des statistiques de passage des
frontières ce qui ne permet guère la
visite mais elle permet en tout cas de
comptabiliser un principe ses
déplacements mais dans la plupart des
pays y compris en france la part du
tourisme et des voyageurs internationaux
n'est qu'une petite partie de l'ensemble
des déplacements touristiques et le
tourisme domestique en france par
exemple où près de 80 % des français
reste pour leurs vacances pour ne parler
qu'à des vacances à domicile si je puis
dire en france montrent que ce sont 20 %
seulement des déplacements qui sont vers
l'étranger ce qui veut dire qu'au total
avec le développement du tourisme dans
la plupart des grands pays
du point de vue démographique y compris
des pays émergents ou des pays qu'il
n'en voyait pas de touristes étrangers
il ya encore quelques décennies eh bien
les chiffres sont très différents ne se
passe à 1 milliard et 2
mais beaucoup plus la chine aujourd'hui
par exemple je terminerai par cet
exemple la chine aujourd'hui à compte
environ 5 milliards de déplacements
touristiques dont seulement 250 millions
de départs vers l'étranger et 5
milliards d'un déplacement en russie que
ça signifie à l'échelle d'un territoire
immense comme la chine des princes âge
de votre relation des créations
d'emplois la mobilité des conséquences
tout à fait un corner sur lequel nous
reviendrons sans doute et pas seulement
que la chine alors justement qu'il y ait
un milliard un milliard et demi de
touristes et que l'on compte comme vous
nous y inviter aussi ceux qui font du
tourisme à l'intérieur de leur propre
pays
après tout ce sont des touristes comme
les autres et ils sont vécus comme telle
la plupart du temps par leurs
compatriotes qui les reçoivent au bord
de la mer ou en eau des montagnes quoi
qu'il arrive en fait ce dont on parle
c'est de la démocratisation du tourisme
on dirait que c'est la démocratisation
du tourisme qui pose problème du temps
il n'y avait que quelques angles
gentemann anglais qui faisaient le tour
d'europe ça m'embêtait personnes
aujourd'hui que ça atteint des millions
des dizaines de millions des centaines
de millions de gens c'est plus
problématique
est-ce qu'on pourrait l'imaginer de le
réduire
on a l'impression que très souvent et
dans la question que nous posons on
sous-entend qu'on pourrait le réduire
est ce que c'est possible
est-ce qu'on peut arriver à ce qu'il y
ait moins de touristes
on sait que le bhoutan le fait avec des
permis pour entrer assez cher d'ailleurs
pour rentrer au bhoutan il ya des
municipalités qui se débrouillent
portofino en italie par exemple si un
tourisme quand même assez chic donc va
multiplier les obstacles que pour que
les autres ne puisse pas entrer
mais grosso modo est ce qu'il serait
possible de réduire le tourisme ce qui
est cousin d'après vous alors d'abord je
voudrais revenir sur cette question de
comment on compte parce que c'est en
fait déterminant candy 1,4 milliard de
touristes en fait c'est comme l'a dit
monsieur michaud 1,4 milliard d'arrivées
internationales avec très peu de gens
qui cinq qui viennent pour se reposer
faire des visites passer des vacances
on estime plutôt que le nombre de
touristes mondiale c'est-à-dire
internationaux et de 500 millions tout
de suite ça change un peu les chiffres
et par contre comme ce qui a été dit on
prend pas en compte ceux qui passent des
vacances qui font du tourisme au sein de
leur pays
donc ça paraît anecdotique mais en fait
c'est fondamental puisque l'ensemble des
statistiques du tourisme
elle a été produit historique moi c'est
toujours le cas paré pour une
organisation mondiale qui est en fait
maîtrisé par l'industrie hôtelière et
l'industrie aérienne
donc en fait on pose pas la question des
pratiques et donc aussi on pose pas la
question de la démocratisation l'accès
aux pratiques puisqu'on est dans une
logique de chiffres et ces chiffres tout
le monde sait qu'ils ne disent rien à la
fois des pratiques et des motivations
donc il faut vraiment pour pause pour
répondre à la question que vous posez il
faut aussi se donner des éléments pour
regarder effectivement ce que les gens
font comment ils le font ils le font et
avec quelle motivation et ça n'est pas
du tout le cas pour le moment en ce qui
concerne la question de la
démocratisation de l'accès aux vacances
c'est d'abord des conquêtes sociales la
réduction du temps de travail l'accès
aux congés payés les choix qui ont été
faits dans un certain nombre de villes
ou qui sont pas être fait comme c'est le
cas à venise qui est finalement de faire
payer plus cher c'est à dire de faire un
choix par l'argent ils paraissent
problématique pour des questions
évidemment démocratique de toute façon
il faut savoir quand j'oublie qu'à 500
millions de gens qui partent en fait en
vacances à l'international le tourisme
est déjà une pratique privilégié à
l'échelle internationale dans ses
pratiques internationales il ya certains
qui vont se concentrer et donc la
question de la démocratisation c est la
fin dès que la question de la
démocratisation à l'arrivée et au départ
c'est à dire peut-être que c'est
compliqué d'avoir trop de monde qui
vient dans les mêmes lieux mais ça veut
dire repenser les politiques à la fois
de départ la question de la répartition
est aussi la question de ouvrons les
gens et ça ça veut dire avoir des
politiques réfléchisse aux images qui
sont véhiculés quand c'est toujours les
mêmes images là même imagerie
touristique du départ sur le lointain
dans certaines destinations
évidemment comme le tourisme est basé au
tourisme de loisirs est basé sur le
désir ben en fait ça amène des
concentrations puisque le tourisme est
basé sur le mimétisme en va dans un
endroit qu'on connaît déjà où on a déjà
entendu parler et qui donne envie d'y
aller ou qui est distinctif donc arriver
à pallier la question continue continuer
à permettre aux gens de partir en
vacances sans
sans avoir ces effets terrifiant de
suroccupation c'est à la fois travailler
sur les indicateurs et c'est travailler
sur des imaginaires jean luc michaud oui
la proche sociologique et celle que
vient de rappeler s'assied cousin est
tout à fait intéressante elle doit aussi
je crois s'appuyer sur une analyse
démographique au moins simple quelques
chiffres simples rester en terminer avec
les chiffres
la population mondiale a triplé depuis
les congés payés
les nations unies estiment que d'ici 5
ans en 2050 la population mondiale sera
pas augmenté encore de plus de 2
milliards et à la fin du siècle
nous serons sans doute à plus de 11
milliards d'habitants dans le monde
évidemment ce sont des personnes qui
avec l'augmentation à l'instar de ce qui
s'est produit dans les pays anciennement
développé déjà plus anciennement
d'europe
naturellement des états unis du japon et
de lancer des adhésions pour faire
simple et bien des populations en
acquérant de nouvelles ressources en
s'ouvrant aussi à de nouvelles
informations sur de nouvelles
destinations de nouveaux pays de
nouvelles cultures et s'approprie en
quelque sorte le désir de voyage et de
partager cette ce bénéfice dont les
catégories les plus fortunées du monde
n'avait jusque là pas les seuls à avoir
bénéficié et par conséquent peut-être
par mimétisme certainement aussi par
envie de déploie par envie de consommer
aussi appartement où les ressources
individuelles progresse dans un certain
nombre de pays et même si elles
progressent de manière très inégalitaire
dans des pays comme l'inde ou bien
d'autres eh bien ce sont de nouveaux
touristes potentiels et ses nouveaux
touristes potentiels
lorsqu'on se rend par exemple en inde
vous voyez quand quelques années les
queues de visite du taj mahal se sont
allongés d'une manière inconcevable et
on se dit en voyant la proportion des
indiens qui visitent leur propre pays et
qui visitent en particulier taj mahal
qui leur première destination de visites
en général et bien qu'on sera t-il dans
20 ou 30 ans c'est à dire que c'est tout
un continent qui s'inscrit dans les
nouvelles formes de la société de
consommation à l'échelle mondiale et
cette évolution qui procède de la
mondialisation des transports de
l'accélération de la mobilité de
l'accélération de la communication à
travers internet et l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux etc tout cela a un
impact sur les comportements qui est
très fort ce n'est pas seulement d'ordre
démographique
c'est en effet à l'heure des
comportements dernière mais aussi les
déplacements de populations des
déplacements de consommation des
transferts de richesse qui accompagne
cette consommation
même si évidemment les dépenses sont
très inégales menegalli terre suivant
les types de tourisme etc
et je voudrais terminer ce point en
souhaitant qu'on distingue ce qui est
l'axé plus large au tourisme des
différentes catégories de population en
fonction de leurs revenus d'origine de
tout ce que l'on voudra et d'autre part
le tourisme de masse
lorsqu'on dit développement autour du
doigt une cela ne signifie pas
nécessairement tourisme de masse c'est
en effet une question de répartition
dans l'espace mais aussi dans le temps
une question de régulation des flux une
question de l'autre d'appropriation des
éléments du patrimoine que l'on a visité
comment respecter comme on le visite est
donc une question aussi d'éducation de
l'ensemble de ces nouveaux des acteurs
aux consommateurs des ressources
touristiques mondiales et je crois que
si nous voulons préserver cette
attractivité des ressources touristiques
dans le monde entier leur diversité leur
richesse inouïe c'est celle des peuples
qu'ils ont construit cette diversité et
ses patrimoines et bien il faut y
veiller
et beaucoup d'initiatives sur lequel
nous allons revenir certainement ils y
ont déjà contribué je pense qu'elles
peuvent être elles doivent être
développées
quand on parle du tourisme de masse on
imagine immédiatement les tours
opérateurs les voyages organisés
des voyages très standardisé
monopolisant beaucoup de touristes au
même moment on sait aujourd'hui que la
tendance est notamment chez les plus
jeunes vers un tourisme beaucoup plus
individualisé aujourd'hui grâce à la
technologie grâce à internet
chacun peut faire ses propres
réservation sans grande difficulté et on
peut faire sourire son voyage sur mesure
comme on le souhaite
n'empêche à la fin c'est quand même la
même chose il ya des gens qui font la
queue pour entrer au musée du louvre
tous à peu près à la même heure et à la
même période qu'ils viennent d'un voyage
organisé ou d'un voyage sur mesure
le tourisme de masse est ce que c'est
pas l'épouvantail qu'on aille vite pour
ne pas avoir à parler du tourisme qui
lui de toute façon et de masse parce que
quand ce qu'il soit 500 millions ou 1
milliard ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de
monde qui veut aller encore une fois on
a la pression
ils veulent tous aller au même endroit
si tu es le chiffre qui disait que 90 %
des touristes fréquentent 5% seulement
des terres immergées qu'ils se
souviennent en voyage organisé ou en
voyages individuels ils vont quand même
au même endroit non c'est le cas cousin
oui alors l'expression de tourisme de
masse elle dit rien sauf on va dire là
une forme de mépris elle parle du mépris
de classe de ceux qui se considèrent pas
comme des touristes
quand vous dites ils vont au même
endroit nous allons tous au même endroit
c'est à dire ceux qui ont la chance
d'avoir un visa et des moyens pour
voyager on voit bien que même en prenant
des circuits différents
le tourisme est une industrie est donc
en fait on participe à cette industrie à
partir du moment où on va utiliser
l'avion l'hôtellerie voilà et donc il ya
un phénomène comme ça de 2,2 par étape
c'est-à-dire il ya des endroits qui sont
d'abord découvert puis ensuite de plus
en plus fréquentes et pour arriver à une
sur fréquentation qui va amener un
mépris par rapport aux personnes qui
vont être très nombreux à venir
mais le tourisme de masse ça veut rien
dire en fait il ya du tourisme de masse
à paris et jusqu'à une période récente
on pourrait revenir en fait il était
absorbé pourquoi parce que les parisiens
eux
partez l'été et parce que les touristes
très nombreux à paris elle est dans ce
qu'on appelle le district touristique
donc finalement le centre de paris il ya
assez peu de gens qui vivent au
quotidien et donc en fait il ya un très
grand nombre de gens qui viennent à
paris mais il n'y a pas ce sentiment là
en tout cas il n'y avait pas ce
sentiment là jusqu'à une période récente
c'est la question la capacité de charge
c'est pas une c'est pas en c'est-à-dire
500 personnes peuvent faire un problème
de capacité de charge dans un village du
burkina faso ça sera pas la même chose
que ce sera beaucoup plus problématique
on va dire que 10 millions de touristes
ou 20 millions touristes à paris une 60
millions de touristes donc faut vraiment
réfléchir a en fait comment est-ce que
commencer personnes sont accueillies
mais le tourisme de masse n'est pas un
concept en fait c'est une manière de
dévaloriser les pratiques des autres
or nous apprécions pratiquants
l'industrie touristique que nous
utilisons ces aménité c'est bien ou non
participants à ce tourisme de masse vous
êtes d'accord jean luc michaud nous
sommes tous des touristes qui faisons du
tourisme de masse même si on a beaucoup
d'argent pour en faire non pas tout à
fait je pense que nous sommes de très
nombreux touristes qui font du tourisme
parfois en masse parfois en se
concentrant mais ce n'est pas je pense
qu'ils caractérisent
l'expression n'est pas bonne tourisme de
masse al'inverse ceux qui veulent s'en
détacher sans distinguer dans tous les
sens du terme emploie volontiers le
terme d'éco tourisme
ce qui donne bonne conscience parce que
c'est censé respecter davantage les
milieux d'accueil les populations
d'accueil et surtout une façon de se
mettre à part me semble-t-il est de
conserver une certaine façon si son
compte asseoir
dès lors qu'on dispose des moyens
notamment financiers culturels de le
faire donc je crois qu'on est souvent
sur un faux débat à ce sujet et partager
c'est l'avis de saskia sur le fait qu'il
ne faut pas d'emploi à temps à travers
termes de tourisme de masse mais plutôt
veiller à ce que par des politiques
adéquates et cela se fait déjà beaucoup
de pays qu'ils soient d'ailleurs porter
ces pays par des politiques de gauche ou
de droite
prenez le cas des seychelles qui est un
pays qui a été inspiré par dix ans les
idéologies non pas socialiste mais
communiste pendant longtemps et bien les
seychelles ont une politique qui est
résolument une politique sélective basé
sur l'argent et ne reçoivent qu'un
nombre contingenté de visiteurs dans des
conditions de qualité voire de luxe qui
sont tout à fait remarquables
donc ce sont des choix qui sont tout à
fait inconnu qui s'appuie sur des
méthodes des techniques de gestion des
flux très en amont parfois à l'arrivée
rarement sur le terrain beaucoup et
notamment et c'est ce à quoi je pense en
france on va payer de plus en plus aussi
payer une meilleure répartition dans
l'espace meilleur répartis dans le camp
de ces flux tout en veillant à la
qualité et à la minimisation effets
négatifs que ces flux peuvent avoir donc
c'est une question de nombre c'est vrai
mais pas nécessairement de masse ou
alors dans le mauvais sens du terme
c'est à dire une concentration
ponctuelle est excessive c'est une
question de nous parce qu'en matière
touristique nous sommes dans les très
grand nombre
les chiffres que j'ai rêvé tout à
l'heure sont là pour le montrer lors
parce qu'on compte le nombre de nuitées
en dizaines de milliards dans le monde
les nuitées touristiques cela donne
l'ampleur du problème et l'ampleur des
problèmes auxquels nous serons
confrontés
de par notamment l'évolution
démographique l'évolution socio culturel
l'évolution économique l'évolution la
mobilité avec ceux ci
à ceci près que nous venons de vivre
plus qu'un tremblement de terre un
tremblement de toute la terre à travers
le coc vide qui a spécialement impacté
le tourisme certains se demandent
pourquoi alors que la réponse est très
simple une épidémie est une pandémie de
caractère mondial c'est un pléonasme
s'accommode dit
difficilement du respect de mouvements
qui le même son audio et le tourisme est
mondialisée part évidemment
l'augmentation de la mobilité donc il
est dont il est partie intégrante à
l'échelle mondiale et ce choc terrible
que beaucoup de pays ont vécu en europe
en particulier et dans les plis des plus
touristiques notamment que ce soit en
italie en france en espagne mais aussi
dans d'autres notes rustique y compris
la grande total et bien ce choc terrible
un effet qui est déjà extrêmement
sensible et qui par rapport au tourisme
de masse que vous évoquez
si l'on prend ce qui figurait en photo
de fond de déclin suffire à l'instant
sur le plateau c'est à dire un bateau de
croisière de grandes dimensions de
vendre capacités sont plusieurs milliers
de personnes
nous sommes dans un tourisme de masse et
le toubib de masse implique une
concentration une proximité et par
conséquent aussi des risques en matière
épidémiologique évidemment de
contamination beaucoup plus rapide et de
difficultés à contrôler cela ça se
produit en matière de santé ça se
produit dans d'autres domaines aussi et
ce point de vue là la concentration vous
interrogez je crois aussi sur les
inconvénients du tourisme la
concentration
lorsqu'elle n'est pas régulé lorsqu'elle
n'est pas maîtrisée lorsqu'elle se
développent dans des endroits
particulièrement fragile en terme
démographique ou culturelles ou en
termes écologiques au sens a des
qualités et des ressources naturelles et
aussi dans culturel c'est cette
aggravation de la concentration qui
constituait un facteur lui même très
négatif pour les pays ou les régions qui
accueillent détruit mais beaucoup
d'initiatives et j'espère qu'on
reviendra ont été prises au niveau
français comme au niveau international
pour parer à cela et revenir dans la
deuxième partie de cette émission mais
là il nous reste quelques minutes dans
la première partie c'est vrai qu'on a un
moment particulier
le tourisme mondial s'est arrêtée
brutalement pendant la crise du coc vide
aujourd'hui des pays comme la france
aimerait bien qu'ils repartent
aujourd'hui c'est nous qui sommes de
vendeurs c'est nous qui demandons qui
espérons que l'écho touristes reviennent
ça n'est pas gagné
peut-être ne reviendront ont-ils pas
avant un certain temps non pas que j'ai
particulièrement peur de ce pays là mais
ils n'ont pas envie de prendre l'avion
ils n'ont pas envie de se retrouver dans
des situations ils sont susceptibles
d'être contaminés et c'est pas vrai
seulement pour la france c'est vrai pour
à peu près tous les pays on voit bien
aujourd'hui il ya une espèce de
tractations entre les pays européens et
des autres
est ce que on a le droit d'aller chez
toi et est ce que tu as le droit d'aller
chez nous et c'est ça se marchande
ça pourrait bien ne pas revenir
j'entends par là qu'en plus il ya le la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
on sait que le tourisme n'est pas très
très bien vu par ceux qui veulent lutter
d'arrache-pied contre le réchauffement
climatique ni les transports aériens est
ce qu'on peut imaginer une période
plus ou moins longue qui pourraient eux
on va dire être une espèce de d'oasis
dans le tourisme
telle qu'on l'a connue depuis quelques
années c'est le cas alors ce qui est qui
est fascinant quand on observe depuis un
certain nombre d'années c'est c'est
notamment sa capacité de ce qu'on
appelle la résilience on l'a vu avec les
attentes a en tout cas dans les pays qui
avaient un fort imaginaire touristique
auparavant on l'a vu avec les attentats
en france notamment donc j'allais dire
malheureusement je ne crois pas du tout
que si rien ne se passe en termes de
politiques publiques la pandémie à moins
qu'elles se poursuivent
arrête totalement enfin parce repenser
l'industrie touristique où se pencher
sur d'autres modes de pratiques
évidemment que cet été il va y avoir des
pratiques qui vont être différentes
j'ai un collègue économiste frédéric
thomas qui a fait une enquête sur sur ce
que les gens veulent faire alors il ya
cette attente de tourisme différent plus
écologique
mais en fait il ya la première attente
c'est surtout pouvoir repartir comme
avant donc d'abord il ya la question de
l'ouverture des frontières
on peut partir ou pas est ce que c'est
on peut avoir une réservation qui risque
de ne pas être annulée est ce qu on
risque de se retrouver en quarantaine
c'est surtout ça les questions qui sont
posées
donc on va avoir un été un peu
spécifique ou finalement va se tester
d'autres formes de pratiques et
notamment peut-être une répartition sur
le territoire français différentes
et puis d un tourisme on appelle
domestique intérieur les gens qui
parlent dans leur propre pays ou en tout
cas en europe mais ça veut pas dire que
tout ne va pas repartir comme avant avec
avec un certain nombre d'enjeux
écologiques puisque vous l'avez dit à
l'industrie notamment l'industrie
aérienne est une des plus grandes
industries polluantes s'il n'y a pas une
réflexion
donc il me semble que ce moment est un
moment assez particulier pour repenser
les politiques publiques du tourisme
parce qu'en fait tu sens qu'il se fasse
sans prise en compte de ça je pense que
tout va repartir comme avant parce que
aussi c'est ce qu'on voit de
l'expérience qu'on a dû des épisodes
précédents où le tourisme a été impacté
notamment par le terrorisme donc vous
êtes d'accord jean-luc bichaud ce sont
les politiques publiques
que qui peuvent réguler tout ça mais ce
ne peut être qu'elle se sera ni
l'industrie touristique ni bien entendu
les touristes qui a priori de presque 17
ski à cousin ne demande qu'une chose
c'est que tout recommence comme avant
oui je crains malheureusement que ce ne
soit pas si rose aussi simple il me
semble qu'il ya d'abord eu un certain
nombre de facteurs qui vont conditionner
fortement cela d'abord la suite de la
vague actuelle
y aura-t-il une suite et ce qu'ils
arrivent dans les pays qui ont déjà été
touchés suite ce massive nous sommes
actuellement je crois un décompte
macabre de cinq cent mille morts dans le
monde ce qui n'est rien par rapport à la
grippe dite espagnole
mais ce qui est beaucoup par rapport au
nombre de morts que l'on recense
habituellement donc il y aura t il une
suite
qu'est ce qui peut éviter une suite ou
du moins une poursuite à mon avis ce
serait des vaccins bien sûr quand
comment pourra-t-il suivre les
évolutions d'un virus éventuellement
mi-temps ce sont aussi les médicaments
qui pourraient être trouvées testé avec
efficacité et accessibilité pour tous
ce sont aussi des aspects psychologiques
car beaucoup de personnes vous le
rappeliez qui ont été conservés ou qui
ont vu des proches touchés par le
comique parfois des cds qui entendu la
propagande où l'information disons pour
être plus respectueux gouvernementale
avec le décompte journalier des morts et
des personnes sous oxygène dans
l'animation
tout cela a marqué les esprits ne nous y
trompons pas et nous savons que il en va
de même dans bien d'autres pays y
compris nos voisins par conséquent c'est
un choc plus profonde me semble-t-il que
ce que nous avons pu connaître avec les
attentats qui était déjà des chocs
considérable naturellement donc et c'est
un truc qui touche toute la planète
par conséquent il est très difficile de
dire aujourd'hui si la reprise
sera progressivement en deux ou trois
ans ou si elle se fera très différemment
et en plus longtemps il y aura de toute
façon des modifications aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de secteurs sont
tétanisés voire non autorisée par lé de
la croisière tout à l'heure mais il y en
a d'autres et le tourisme ce ne sont pas
que les vacances même si c'est l'image
qui prévaut le tourisme c'est aussi de
l'événementiel ce sont les jeux
olympiques
ce sont les grandes manifestations qui
peuvent se tenir à cannes ou ailleurs du
mipim donc de caractère professionnel ce
sont de très grande variété d'activités
de grandes de moindre ampleur mais qui
crée beaucoup d'emplois sur des
territoires très différent parfois de
ceux des vacances et qui par conséquent
participe d'une certaine façon aussi à
la répartition sur le territoire mais
qui sont aussi touchés par ces problèmes
de concentration notamment s'il s'agit
des grands événements je vous attends
jean paul jean luc michaud pardon je
vous interromps fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
ça fait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
qui a un certain nombre d'événements
inattendus qui bouleverse est fort d'un
mondial on essaie le faire perdurer mais
on est à la fin d'un modèle qui était le
tout misé sur la dette c'est la tête et
la relance par la dette ou par la
création monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement on l'a dit des milliers
de fois c'est pas en imprimant des
billets que vous relancer une économie
si on essaie autant de relancer la
croissance économique s'est
fondamentalement on sait on sait pas
faire ce en passant c'est connu je peux
pas continuer à diffuser des chiffres
qui sont absolument faux simplement
parce que ça arrange monsieur trump à ce
moment là
[Musique]
vous maintenez le traitement à base
d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie trop
missing malgré la polémique mondiale sur
l'efficacité de cette combinaison nous
avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les dirty kids bien avant
que le match ne commence en effet par
sénégal la chloroquine domaniale est
utilisé pendant des décennies et des
décennies ça pourrait faire sourire les
sénégalais que j'entends il n'y a pas de
signes qui m'est rendu
[Musique]
donc pendant ce débat sur le tourisme
avec jean luc michaud qui est le
président de l'institut français du
tourisme et avec saskia cousin qui est
anthropologue spécialisé dans les
pratiques touristiques où on sait bien
les avantages qu'il peut y avoir au
tourisme
ça rapporte des devises et ça crée des
emplois
on assiste - en général sur les
inconvénients la saturation
le fait qu'on ne ne peux plus aller nous
parisien il est devenu très difficile
d'aller au louvre ou de monter sur la
tour eiffel tout simplement parce que
les touristes prennent toute la place
il ya la dégradation des sites aussi sur
lequel on on s'apitoie peu mais pourtant
il suffit de regarder ce qu'est devenu
le bas de la tour eiffel aujourd'hui
pour se dire que c'était quand même
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus joli
caen ne s'était pas comme ça
il ya la monoactivité aussi qu' autour
des monuments des sites touristiques
il suffit de regarder autour de notre
dame notre dame qui n'est plus visités
par les touristes aujourd'hui mais met
autour de notre dame il n'y a plus que
des boutiques pour les touristes des
restaurants pour les touristes des cafés
pour les touristes autant d'heureux
droit qui n'intéresse plus les gens qui
habitent ici y compris ceux qui habitent
autour de notre dame d'ailleurs il
habita quartiers touristiques et on sait
ce que c'est un karité de touristique
voilà tout ça sans compter les nuisances
sonores et environnementales la pression
même sur les prix à la consommation où
les prix de l'immobilier
on a l'impression qu'on assiste pas là
dessus les grecs l'ont fait autrefois
les italiens les français pas tellement
encore je me trompe
le tourisme comme mono industrie a un
problème comme tout les mono industrie
enfin si vous prenez l'industrie lumière
enfin toutes les industries automobile
et vous allez dans des fils qui vivaient
uniquement de l'industrie automobile ou
de l'industrie minière et bien il y
avait des retombées économiques de
l'emploi et un certain nombre d'effets
collatéraux plus ou moins usi bhl donc
en fait le problème c'est la question de
la mono industrie mais ça c'est à toutes
les échelles que ça soit dans le marais
à paris pour les effets notamment
immobiliers des locations des balles
courtes un type airbnb ou autour de la
tour eiffel comme vous l'avez dit je
suis pas sûr que tous les parisiens
rêvent de monter la tour eiffel mais
aussi dans d'autres pays à partir du
moment où on a une mono industrie c'est
très problématique
mais ça n'est pas ça n'est pas lié au
tourisme c'est lié au fait qu'on a une
âme l'industrie qui a été mondialisée au
20e siècle et qui est globalisée
aujourd'hui avec une mainmise notamment
des entreprises et des plateformes
globales qui se pose évidemment pas la
question des nuisances pour les
personnes qui ne participent pas de
cette maison industrie mais est ce qu'il
n'ya pas mono industrie parce que
l'industrie touristique chasse le reste
à part il n'y a pas de mono industrie on
a plein d'autres industries il se trouve
que là où il ya les touristes
tout le monde s'en va
plus personne ne veut venir non genre un
jean luc michaud we hear beaucoup de ça
il ya d'une part je prends
mono-industrie par défaut c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a beaucoup de régions dans
lesquelles le tourisme se développe
parce qu'on va le chercher parce qu'on
va chercher les touristes parce qu'on
crée des événements parce qu'on crée des
animations parce qu'on développe les
ressources parce que la région pour
vivre pour survivre en a besoin parce
que l'agriculture est défaillant parce
que l'industrie a lâché prise depuis
longtemps et c est à moins de laisser la
désertification des trois quarts de
notre territoire s'opérer beaucoup le
pensent beaucoup d'élus locaux en
particulier beaucoup de responsables
économiques locaux ont considéré qu'il
fallait sans doute faire un effort se
ressaisir pour donner une deuxième
chance une deuxième vie à des
territoires qui sont un groupe d errance
à paris c'est un peu l'un verse à paris
c'est ce que vous n'êtes écrire c'est à
dire une entreprise comme airbnb à
tendance naturellement en faire son pré
carré si tu dire m'indigner de plus rond
et à coloniser de l'été certaine manière
la ville de paris avec des touristes qui
envahissent j'admire comme le la
mauvaise graine peut-être les mauvaises
herbes
c'est à dire sans contrôle sans
limitation avec des effets
essentiellement négatif en effet des
effets positifs sans doute pour les
quelques restaurateurs qui ont la chance
de recevoir un visiteur d'airbnb comme
ce ne serait pas sa cuisine dans
l'appartement qui va jouer etc
mais tout cela c'est en effet là des
dangers qui guettent évolution du taux
est de mondialiser
c'est à dire la perte d'attention de
leur propre territoire de leur propre
cadre de vie de leur propre culture à
terme par un certain nombre de l'année
tant de régions non seulement rural mais
aussi urbaine maintenant et paris
barcelone et d'autres en sont
malheureusement des exemples donc ça
c'est une question qui demande une
régulation d'ordre mondial et beaucoup
de propositions ont été faites certaines
ont été suivies mais bien peu par des
organisations sont professionnels soit
les pouvoirs publics soit même au niveau
communautaire pour essayer de
mieux contrôler cela mais il y aussi des
bonnes initiatives je pense en
particulier ce qui a été développé
depuis une bonne dizaine d'années à
l'initiative de la france d'ailleurs
pour avec les nations unies avec le
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement trouver des meubles de
développement qui soit en effet durable
pas seulement sur des niches
touristiques présenté à quelques-uns
mais qu'ils puissent assurer un nouvel
équilibre une progression des
transformations qui soit acceptable par
le milieu par le milieu y compris par
conséquent parce qu'ils vivent déjà et
d'abord pour ceux qui vivent déjà sur
place mais qu'ils puissent sa culture et
ce qui impose en effet des régulations
non seulement quantitatif mais également
qualitative
il y a beaucoup de procéder pour cela
beaucoup a été fait pour par des labels
arrêté à favoriser ce mouvement est
aujourd'hui des dizaines de pays dans le
monde ont suivi cette initiative du coin
des insurgés ni pour l'environnement à
travers ce que l'on être qualifié de
partenariat mondial pour le
développement durable du tourisme donc
pas à penser à notre pays je veux dire
en tout cas à je crois fait des choix
pertinents qui en tout cas ont été
suivies pour certains d'entre eux au
niveau mondial mais néanmoins la france
ne représente que 1% de la population
mondiale ces moyens budgétaires sont de
plus en plus limitées et par conséquent
elle ne veut pas faire à la place des
autres
par contre aujourd'hui les enjeux change
de dimension avec la prise de conscience
à l'échelle européenne du fait que ce
choc terrible pour une grande partie de
l'économie du continent
concernant le tourisme risquent d'être
irréversibles pour bourdais beaucoup
d'activités intuit en termes d'emploi
qui ne sont pas que des inconvénients
liés au tourisme et qui sont bien comme
vous l'avez dit des avantages et bien
les aveugles et les les centaines de
milliers d'emplois qui risquent de
disparaître aujourd'hui parmi les cinq
cent mille chômeurs de plus ce que l'on
attend trois entrées
c'est un problème collectif et
naturellement ce n'est pas par
l'affaissement accrue du tourisme qu'il
trouvera sa solution il faut en trouver
des moyens de transformation de rebond
de relance et lydia tive européenne
à mon sens la france devrait en tirer un
parti plus grand que ce qui est prévu
aujourd'hui puisque il est prévu 750
milliards pour aider à la relance et la
transformation de l'économie européenne
après l aco vide dont seulement 38
milliards par mois milliards sur 750
milliards sont fléchés vers la france la
france a été l'un des pays les plus
touchés par le mobile
la france est un des pays les plus
impactés par la débâcle qui touche entre
autres et notamment le tourisme
donc la france serait bien inspirée
semble-t-il de négocier fortement la
manière dont le continent et l'union
européenne vont s'impliquer dans cette
relance de notre commune iv avait été
chargé d'ailleurs une étude sur par
l'union européenne avec huit autres pays
l'étude sur les le devenir des du tissu
des tpe puisque le tourisme est d'abord
une affaire de toutes petites
entreprises à travers l'europe
même s'il ya quelques monstres
malheureusement ça créé pour venir avec
des capitaux massifs européen ou ou plus
lointains s'approprie en quelque sorte
des espaces entiers et confisqué mais il
y à la croix un enjeu considérable et
pour reprendre rebondir sur ce que
disait saskia est ce qu'on va s'en
sortir ou non est ce que la chute sera
durable je pense que ce plan de relance
et de d'adaptation que je vois un grand
rôle dans l'accélération de la reprise
mais rien n'est joué rien n'est encore
vraiment décidé d'ailleurs tout le monde
réfléchit vous conditions de cette
transformation et de cette relance c'est
une bonne chose ça prouve que les
esprits eux mêmes évoluent encore
faut-il que les faits derrière
accompagne cette évolution alors comment
ne pas devenir ben ali ou les îles
grecques ou la place du tertre parce que
ça peut être aussi des endroits comme ça
très ponctuelle à paris ou ailleurs
il ya des place du tertre un peu partout
en france où plus personne ne veut aller
à part le touriste et encore il ya même
beaucoup de touristes qui ne vont plus
passe du tarp parce qu'ils savent que
s'adapte rien de temps tic plus rien
d'intéressant que ça n'est que de la
verroterie pour les touristes comment
éviter ce type de destin c'est ce qui en
fera
et venise est également une ville
absolument magnifique mais à part en ce
moment qui a envie d'aller à venise
c'est ce qu'a cousin est ce qu'il ya des
méthodes est-ce qu'on peut éviter
sachant que de toute façon les gens ont
envie d'aller à venise ils ont envie
d'aller à montmartre ils ont envie
d'aller à bali
mais en même temps ce qu'on leur propose
n'a plus rien à voir ni avec montmartre
ni avec venise
eric ben ali alors il ya deux choses il
ya le fait de penser que comme certaines
classes sociales éduquer ceux qui
cherchent à échapper aux touristes pour
avoir un voyage différent serait quelque
chose d'universel c'est faux c'est à
dire beaucoup de gens le la
concentration le fait de de se retrouver
avec du monde et de pouvoir se dire
qu'on a fait du tourisme et que
d'ailleurs on est allé là où il faut
aller parce qu'il ya du monde ça fait
partie aussi des objectifs est en soi il
n'ya pas à les dénigrer mais simplement
il ya une partie de la population qui en
fait une petite partie de la population
occidentale sur éduqués et socialiser au
tourisme depuis longtemps qui considère
que c'est un problème
donc du point de vue il n'ya pas à
porter un jugement de valeur par contre
ça pose un problème en termes de
capacité de charge et là il ya un
problème c'est à dire qu'on sait qu'il
ya des cycles touristique de l'invention
des lieux de découverte
et puis ça devient des chemins et des
sentiers qui deviennent des chemins puis
des routes des autoroutes
et puis à la fin il ya on peut arriver à
la rhune touristique à une réinvention
ça existe dans certains cas où
finalement on vient visiter du
patrimoine du tourisme c'est le cas
notamment par exemple de stations
thermales qui avait qui avait fermé ou
d'autres choses mais ça c'est des cycles
qu'on connaît le problème c'est à quel
moment il ya une bascule ou pas c'est ce
qui s'est passé il ya barcelone en 2000
en fait on peut on peut on sait d'après
les études que il ya des moments où les
politiques qui avait été fait qu'ils
utilisent et du tourisme pour faire de
l'urbain par exemple bascule à partir du
moment où les clés sont donnés aux
politiques touristiques c'est-à-dire
touristique de tourisme n'est plus un
moyen de faire autre chose de l'emploi
de l'urbain mais ça devient une finalité
donc c'est très compliqué je n'en doute
pas mais vraiment il ya une réflexion à
avoir sur cette question là et à venise
les historiens date 7 cette ville qui se
transforme pour le tourisme pour les
clients de façon encore plus antérieure
en fait plutôt au 18e ou 19e siècle donc
il ya des cycles
ça pose des problèmes non pas en valeur
ça pose des problèmes en termes de
capacité de charge d'environnements
voilà
après qu'il ait des gens qui a envie de
se serrer les uns les autres sur les
plages année c'est pas un problème
déontologique c'est un problème
écologique ça peut être un problème
social ça peut évidemment un problème
sanitaire en cette période
tout à l'heure on a parlé de tourisme de
masse et là il a été question de l'offre
moi il me semble qu'il ya aussi une
réflexion à avoir sur la demande c'est à
dire ce qu'on appelle les vacances
populaire la manière dont un certain
nombre de gens partent en vacances et en
général ils partent en vacances sur leur
territoire il perd le prennent assez peu
l'avion ils vont pour partie seulement
dans l'hébergement marchand
pour ce qui est des français ben aknoun
ans majorité restent en france a et vont
à moins de quatre heures de route dans
leur pays
et là il ya quelque chose qui est
dévalorisé socialement aller se planter
dans le même camping depuis 30 ans et
avoir des promenades en forêt et qui en
fait dit qu'elle peint sur lequel on
pourrait s'appuyer pour repenser les
vacances mais quand on sait que 50 %
seulement des gens vont dans de
l'hébergement marchand cela veut dire
que les autres ils vont ailleurs
et peut-être qu'il ya des choses à
repenser et on revient à la question des
indicateurs de soutien en vacances
populaire cette année on va avoir
beaucoup de gens déjà il ya 40% des gens
voire 50 qui partait en vacances l'été
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens pour
des questions de revenu à sa robe de
gens ont perdu une partie de leurs
congés payés
cet été puisqu'ils ont été mis en congés
payés et forcé il ya peut-être quelque
chose à penser aujourd'hui sur comment
en fait refaire partir l'économie locale
du tourisme et une diffusion plus large
sur les territoires ce soit en france ou
dans chacun des pays en soutenant
finalement les vacances populaire qui
elle en fait sont des vacances c'est à
dire les premières en jeu c'est pas
d'aller aussi place du tertre où est la
tour eiffel c'est d'abord de se
retrouver en famille entre amis et avoir
des pratiques sur tout le territoire et
on sait que les bénéfices dans ce cas là
ils sont mieux réparties on sait aussi
parce que vous le disiez il ya il ya
quand même plus de gens à part mis à
part depuis la crise du que vides il ya
plus de gens qui partent en vacances que
de gens qui n'en parlent pas qu'il parte
pas en france ça s'est inversé et
deuxièmement il ya aussi des gens qui ne
partent pas en vacances tout simplement
parce qu'ils habitent sur des lieux de
vacances les gens qui avaient la chance
d'habiter au bord de la mer enfin tant
que la mère ne monte pas ben ils n'ont
pas de raison de partir en vacances ils
restent chez eux et ils sont néanmoins
dans des lieux de vacances souvent que
les autres leurs envies donc il faut il
faut tenir compte de cela aussi non oui
alors on peut très bien inviter au bord
de la mer et avoir envie au soleil avoir
envie d'aller dans un pays où il pleut
faire la loi
et justement fuir la saison touristique
donc ça ça mais on sait qu effectivement
il ya plus de gens du nord pas de calais
qui partent en vacances dans le sud que
gens du sud qui vont partir en vacances
en vacances dans le nord
mais je pense pas que ça soit
fondamentalement le problème le problème
il est là il ya une pandémie qui a
stoppé le tourisme mondial
mais il n'a pas stoppé le tourisme
national à parler tourisme nationaux ou
potentiellement en tout cas il est
permis puisque les frontières sont
ouvertes et puis c'est plus facile
un certain nombre de gens vont partir en
fait mais ils vont partir chez des amis
ils vont partir dans la famille parce
que y'a pas le risque d'avoir une
réservation qui va être stoppé le risque
d'une quarantaine etc et donc tous et
toutes ces personnes là ils partent si
on va quand c'est pas la même évidemment
si on parle uniquement d'un point de vue
économique et du point de vue de
l'industrie le tourisme
on voit un effondrement et on se pose la
question de comment est-ce qu'on va
relancer cette économie là est
évidemment qu'elle est important que si
on part du point de vue des pratiques
on peut aussi s'inspirer de ces
pratiques pour repenser un peu
différemment
aussi la question de l'accueil la
question pour sortir de cette fiction de
l'idée que les gérants il y aurait
forcément dans l'hébergement marchand et
ce qu'ils recherchent et il a été
question du fait que le tourisme est
essentiellement une question de très
petites entreprises
mais par exemple encore une fois c'est
une question le touriste qui pensaient
comme un marché l'exportation
aujourd'hui ce n'était pas le cas il ya
20 ans comment est-ce qu'on repense le
tourisme comme une politique économique
et une politique sociale à l'échelle de
chacun des pays et ça ça peut avoir des
effets très différents jean luc michaud
oui il faudrait pas laisser penser que
rien n'a été fait dans ces domaines là
au contraire jeu
ce que le chèque vacances par exemple a
été créée après il ya près de 40 ans est
une réussite
il ya 4 millions de bénéficiaires ou
moins par an de la semaine à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui avec les difficultés que
l'on connaît et compte tenu aussi de la
tendance qui a prévalu intense sur les
directives gouvernementales rester près
de chez soi pour ses vacances pâques ont
100 km ensuite dans la région enfin bref
beaucoup d'incitation dans ce sens
beaucoup de régions où une demi-douzaine
je crois se sont engagés dans des
politiques complémentaires de celles des
chèques vacances mais par un système de
chèques-vacances muhlmann associé au
chac existants de manière à offrir à des
ressortissants partir en méritant dans
certains cas ça peut être des soignants
ça peut être des personnages de
différentes catégories ou japonais telle
ou telle catégorie de population à très
faibles revenus que sous la forme d'un
chèque complémentaires utilisable dans
la région qui émet ces chèques
cela incite à fréquenter précisément la
région dans laquelle se trouvent ses
habitants là et puis il y à aussi la
tendance que l'on connaît depuis
toujours c'est-à-dire une très forte
fréquentation surtout en période
difficile du logement chez des parents
ou chez des amis ou dans la résidence
secondaire qu'on partage avec des amis
c'est sans doute un peu accentués par le
risque sanitaire qui est encore perçue
aujourd'hui ça ne me paraît pas de moins
une évolution fondamentale aujourd'hui
quel comportement ou al ahmar mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on observe sur le
terrain d'après les sources dont on peut
disposer avec toutes les imprécisions
très 1 comporte bien sur une reprise qui
est très lente qui est très lente
un nombre d'emplois ou de demandeurs
d'emplois qui vont rester sur le carreau
c'est une des raisons d'air pour
lesquels à la demande du gouvernement
l'institut français du tourisme à mettre
en place cette semaine c'est un scoop
une plateforme numérique
la première du genre pour favoriser
l'accès notamment des jeunes puisque
dans les circonstances présentes ce sont
surtout les saisonniers et notamment les
jeunes qui sont victimes de cette crise
et de la non ouverture de nombreux
établissements des noms d'offres
d'emploi par rapport à l'habitude et
bien leur donner la possibilité en se
rendant sur le site
le site mon emploi tourisme tout
simplement de bénéficier d'offres
d'emploi auxquels ils n'auraient pas
forcément accès est seul dans l'ensemble
des secteurs du tourisme des dizaines de
grands partenaires professionnels et
syndicaux ont accepté de soutenir cette
initiative
donc c'est une belle initiative et je
crois qu elle serait utile pour autant
qu'elle soit connue et donc merci de
cette occasion a dit reconnaître vous
êtes d'accord tous les deux pour dire
qu'il faut au fond que le les touristes
au lieu de tous aller au même endroit se
répartissent dans d'autres endroits
j'ai l'impression que c'est quelque
chose qui est à l'oeuvre depuis assez
longtemps maintenant on a inventé le
tourisme des casinos monte carlo on a
bénéficié puis las vegas ce qui est
quand même une ville perdue au milieu de
nulle part et qui est à risque y est
parvenu à drainer des millions de
voyageurs des millions de touristes
uniquement pour pouvoir jouer au casino
il ya le le tourisme de la drogue on
sait que amsterdam a eu un tourisme
absolument considérable au cours des
vingt dernières années essentiellement
parce que c'est législation très
tolérante à l'égard du cannabis a drainé
amsterdam les gens des pays voisins
il ya le tourisme de la danse à ibis a
par exemple pourquoi est ce que les gens
vont tous sur cette petite île
uniquement pour danser il ya le tourisme
sexuel aussi bien en thaïlande et à cuba
je veux dire par là est-ce que ça n'est
pas ça l'avenir du tourisme
au fond c'est que chacun invente
un truc culturel parce que tous à
offenser du tourisme culturel
on n'y va pas pour se baigner ou pour
faire du sport parce qu'on participe
d'une culture
est-ce que ça dépasse à l'avenir du
tourisme daigné se baigner faire du
sport ces traits culturels en fait le
fait de se positionner
j'ai trouvé que c'est agréable c'est
c'est très socialement construit est en
fait assez récent dans l'histoire
occidentale et voilà tu patiente le
tourisme sexuel soit fondamentalement
culturel donc là on parle de niche en
fait qu'ils sont construits avec des
territoires qui cherchent à ceux
spécifiés en fait aidé à chercher leurs
avantages comparatifs
je pense qu'à amsterdam et l'ofii
stories d'aspe adam serait pas forcément
d'accord avec votre vision de ce que les
gens via le faire comme ça il ya la
question du nombre de flux que de gens
qui vont passer la frontière et
puisqu'ils vont faire qui va faire quoi
combien de temps les gens vont passer
aux pays-bas et et amsterdam
donc en fait la question c'est comment
se situe dans une offre globale et
qu'est ce qu'on à mettre en avant deux
différentes des autres mais ça c'est
plutôt une question de marketing que de
sociologie donc je répondrai pas enfin
je suis pas du tout spécialiste de la
question
mais c'est pas ça qui va empêcher la
concentration parce que en ce moment en
période de pandémie et de cordes à virus
je suis pas sûr que aller à las vegas et
échapper à enfin voila c'est certain
nous allons sûrement c'est parle comme
un dieu ont repris les effets de
concentration donc ce qui est l'enjeu
c'est justement d'échapper à ça c'est à
dire que c'est une question très
complexe
c'est comment on donne en fait on ouvre
les imaginaires pour permettre aux gens
d'imaginer aller ailleurs que là où on
va de m'adresser des chemins absolument
balisé en leur disant qu'ils ne peuvent
pas aller ailleurs
donc c'est aller à l'encontre justement
de ces politiques de marketing et de ses
politiques qui visent à s'identifier
comme niches et à créer des couloirs où
tout le monde va devoir prendre ce coup
a échoué à dire entre telles pratiques
ou telle pratique
mais on sait très bien que d'autres
façons des touristes si vous récupérez
ils auront peut-être des activités où
ils vont danser ou des activités
sexuelles mais ils vont pas faire que ça
quand voit observable j'ai pas sûr qu'on
aille à part ceux qui passent la
frontière pour aller s'acheter une
barrette de haschich je suis pas sûr que
quand on va à amsterdam en vacances
c'est uniquement pour en tout cas ça
déconne
et personne que l'on observe ce soit
uniquement dans cet objectif la comète
si on regarde en termes de niche et
d'offres on va seriez et pratique
sauf que quand on regarde quand les gens
partent en vacances ils vont faire du
tourisme culturel ils vont aller au
restaurant ils vont se poser sur une
plage je veux faire une promenade en
forêt enfin c'est un ensemble de choses
la question c'est comment on est capable
en fait politiquement socialement
d'ouvrir les imaginaires c'est à dire
aussi de changerait l'image l'imagerie
qui associe à chaque pays puis à chaque
région qui à chaque destination qui à
chaque ville une image précise et en
faisant ça elle canalise elle centralise
à la fois les flux et donc les
problématiques de sur fréquentation donc
enfin de cela ça dépend de la curiosité
des touristes c'est comment est-ce qu'on
peut susciter cette curiosité comment
parce que la curiosité petit oui c'est
encore faire reposer en fait l'ensemble
des pratiques sur / en fait l'idée que
des touristes y aurait là où on leur dit
de palet mais en fait les touristes quel
que soit leur niveau de revenus ou leur
niveau d'études vont dans des endroits
qu'ils ont dont ils ont déjà entendu
parler
si je joue pour ça que je parle de
curiosité il faut qu'ils ont fait non
parce que vous ne vous n'avez pas envie
d'aller dans un endroit dont vous n'avez
jamais entendu parler le tueur si je te
dis si je vous dis part à tout c'est une
ville formidable
vous savez pas où c'est enfin il n'y a
pas une question d' imaginaires ça qui a
déjà alors c'est peut-être par la
littérature par d'autres biais parisien
vers d'autres milk du tourisme mais
c'est justement ouvrir cet imaginaire et
ouvrir ces images pour diversifier en
fait et créer des désirs autre que celui
qui est distinctif qu'il faut avoir dans
sa vie être allé au taj mahal sur la
tour eiffel et c'est à dire à travers
aussi donc les films la bande dessinée
la littérature avoir une autre vision du
monde et c'est le cas notamment en
afrique subsaharienne en fait il ya qu'
un pays est très peu touchée par un
certain nombre de pays ici sont très peu
touché par la pandémie
et pourtant les dans les enquêtes on
voit que les gens considèrent que c'est
celle ans et plus dont vous avez
pourquoi c'est un imaginaire pur alors
que même aujourd'hui il vaut mieux vivre
au sénégal par exemple
quand en europe là où vous vous trouvez
d'ailleurs actuellement jean louis
pichot dernier mouy et noailles est
devenue une vision très intéressante
mais très incomplète je pense
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup se demandent
comment éviter précisément la
dégradation des régions des pays
décident d'accueil par des moyens qui
peuvent certes être logiquement avancé
par exemple aujourd'hui en virtuel vous
pouvez visiter nombreuses destinations
en virtuel et c'est de plus en plus
recherchés vous pouvez également
dupliqué des sites et céderait par
exemple avec commercial the grove est
bien d'autres sites en france ou
ailleurs ou dupliquer les sites et vous
y attirer une population touristique
intéressés par la réalité qu'elles
soient copiés ou originales et danse à
20h15 alors que les copies sont deux se
sont très très sophistiqué ça vote en
effet plus que le détour
et puis vous avez une part de rêve les
gars mais vous avez une grande partie
des visiteurs de las vegas qui
choisissent cette destination parce que
c'est un substitut aussi d'une visite
appareil d'une visite à venise pour ceux
qui ont vu les évolutions récentes de
las vegas et de ses ressources
c'est absolument fabuleux et enfin bien
que les dépasse acta qui préfèrent la
copie à l'original ça peut paraître à
une
mais sur eux si vous pensez aussi que
les bons pas peut-être bien que non non
non je pense que l'original est très
intéressant parce que c'est un incident
de réussite sociale où beaucoup le
voyage lointain est ainsi de réussite
sociale
la visite dont on peut parler et dont on
peut apporter non seulement les photos
mais aussi des souvenirs et qc ça fait
partie de ce qui n'est pas l'imaginaire
de ce qui est ce que l'on rapporte dans
ce valorisant socialement auprès de sa
famille de ses amis et ses c'est bien
connu mais aussi le fait de pouvoir en
un lieu tel que las vegas pratiquer des
activités multiples et il ya bien
d'autres choses que les casinos je ne
ferai pas la publicité et bien d'autres
choses que les casinos et compris sur le
plan culturel mais aussi pour visiter
des coquilles qui sont tout à fait
étonnantes parfois de réalisme on pense
au fond palais vénitien scélérat et qui
ont été construits donc il y à une des
formes de duplication des destinations
touristiques les technologies parfois
contribuer à faire de ce tourisme
virtuel une vraie activité véritable
activité en tout cas c'est une industrie
par la production de ce type de vidéos
accessibles par casque que l'on
développe écarte donc il y a de ce point
de vue beaucoup d'imagination qui
s'applique à ce secteur
le tourisme de ce train du favorise
l'imagination y compris pour les
entrepreneurs beaucoup de start up se
développe autour ou sur le thème de
l'entreprise ou une tour des produits
touristiques et il faut se réjouir parce
que cela crée non seulement de l'emploi
mais ça crée surtout beaucoup de produit
de l'imagination qu'on peut être aussi
exporté et je repars rapport à cela
comme le titre de l'émission appels il
est interdit d'interdire en matière
touristique
c'est je crois un grand avantage merci
tous les deux d'avoir participé à cette
édition merci pour ce débat merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
oui